[Musik]
Wallstreet Zentralbanken und
Privatinvestoren haben eines gemeinsam
sie haben ein wachsendes Interesse an
kryptowährungen laut coinchers
erreichten die Investitionen in Krypto
Fonds und Produkte im ersten Quartal
dieses Jahres einen Rekordwert von 4,5
Milliarden Dollar das Vermögen in den
USA beträgt 140 Billionen Dollar
weltweit sogar 400 ein halbes Prozent
des globalen Vermögens ist in
kryptowährungen angelegt bis zum Ende
des Jahres werden wir wohl einen Prozent
erreicht haben Bitcoin bekommt die
meiste Aufmerksamkeit unter seinen
krypto-kollegen doch Kritikern haben
Bedenken in Hinsicht der Struktur und
ihrer Volatilität im Wesentlichen haben
wir nur ein weiteres Tauschmittel
erschaffendes irgendwo in einem Computer
existiert es hat keinen echten Wert
keinen Nutzen und liefert keine
brauchbaren Dienste es ist eine Blase es
ist die zugrunde liegende Technologie
einer blockchain die das Interesse der
Investoren weckt laut CB insights haben
Start-ups die sich auf blockchain
konzentrieren allein im ersten Quartal
dieses Jahres
Milliarden Dollar eingesammelt das ist
mehr als im gesamten Jahr 2020 in
Wirklichkeit sehen wir hier den Aufbau
einer Infrastruktur auf der tatsächlich
Transaktionen durchgeführt werden können
auch die Zentralbanken spüren den Druck
eigene digitalwährungen zu schaffen eine
kürzlich durchgeführte Umfrage der
Banken ergab das 86 Prozent der
Zentralbanken der Zeit daran arbeiten
2017 waren es noch 65%
an diesem Punkt frage ich mich ob
Bitcoin nicht teilweise als eine Art
finanzwaffe Chinas gegen die USA
angesehen werden sollte es bedroht nicht
nur das Fiat Geld es bedroht vor allem
den US-Dollar
doch wie denkt Europa über
kryptowährungen die Digitalisierung ist
mittlerweile in allen Bereichen unseres
Lebens spürbar und hat bereits die Art
und Weise wie wir bezahlen verändert ein
digitaler Euro wäre ein Symbol für den
Fortschritt in Europa und die
europäische Integration
er würde als Geld in elektronischer Form
vom Eurosystem der EZB und den
nationalen Zentralbanken des Euroraums
ausgegeben und könnte gleichermaßen von
Privatpersonen und Unternehmen verwendet
werden das Bargeld würde durch ihn nicht
ersetzt sondern ergänzt
[Musik]
wer weiß wie die Zukunft der Banken
aussehen wird einer der es vielleicht
wissen könnte ist Ravi Mennen er war bis
2011 Staatssekretär im Ministerium für
Handel und Industrie und leitet nun die
Zentralbank eines Landes das als eines
der intelligentesten und
fortschrittlichsten Finanzzentren der
Welt gilt Singapur
[Musik]
Ravi Mennen vielen Dank dass Sie sich
heute Zeit genommen haben
Ravi vor nicht allzu langer Zeit hielten
sich sie Zentralbanken von digitalen
Währungen komplett fern aber die Lage
hat sich verändert ich meine wir haben
Länder wie Schweden die Bahamas und
China die darüber reden möglicherweise
Ihre eigene digitale Währung in Umlauf
zu bringen wie sollten Zentralbanken in
Sachen digitale Währung in Zukunft
involviert sein
ja ich denke wir sollten hier unbedingt
involviert sein das heißt wir müssen mit
der Technologie Schritt halten auch wenn
wir dabei am Anfang viel Lehrgeld
bezahlen durch das Jazz bei ubenprojekt
konnten wir wertvolle Erfahrungen
sammeln als wir unsere digitale Währung
den Singapur Dollar auf einer blockchain
in Umlauf gebracht haben ich denke es
ist wichtig sich mit dieser Technologie
auseinanderzusetzen und sich nicht davor
zu verstecken
war ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt des
kanadischen blockchain-netzwerks Korda
und das quorum- in Singapur aus einer
Kooperation der monetary alpharity of
Singapur und der kanadischen Zentralbank
wurde 2016 untersucht ob es einfachere
und effizientere zahlungs- und
abwicklungssysteme durch die Ausgabe
digitaler Token mit Hilfe der
Zentralbanken geben kann in der ersten
Phase wurde ein digitales
tokenäquivalent des singapur-dollars
ausgegeben dieser beruhte auf einer
Proof of Concept basierenden blockchain
den als capcoin bezeichneten kanadischen
digitalen Dollar entwickelte man um zu
verstehen wie blockchains in realen
zahlungsabwicklungsszenarien genutzt
werden können Phase 2 stand für die
Einführung von Software Prototypen für
interbanken Zahlungen hauptsächlich war
Microsoft damit beauftragt diese
Prototypen in ihrer blockchain
bereitzustellen in der letzten Phase
wurden Möglichkeiten zur Integration der
Plattform und der digitalen Assets unter
Wahrung der Privatsphäre der
Marktteilnehmer untersucht Jasper uwin
war ein voller Erfolg so konnten die
Bank of Kanada und die monetary of
fortity of Singapur Versuch ein
schnelleres und kostengünstigeres
grenzüberschreitendes Zahlungssystem
entwickeln
denn wir müssen unsere Perspektive etwas
ändern und uns Fragen zu welchem Zweck
was soll eine digitale Währung leisten
müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen einer
grenzüberschreitenden Handelswährung und
einer einzelhandelswährung für
Konsumenten bei einer digitalen
Handelswährung würde es sich um genau
das Handeln was wir als blockchain
kennen es kommt hier nicht auf jeden
einzelnen digitalen Token an aber in
Summe werden mit ihrer Hilfe die
eigentlichen Transaktionen durchgeführt
nach diesem System würde zumindest
Singapur eine digitale Währung in Umlauf
bringen Kanada würde gerne eine digitale
Währung herausgeben um
grenzüberschreitenden Zahlungsverkehr zu
vereinfachen aber sie kommen nicht so
einfach aus ihrem Bankensystem heraus
weil die Leute immer noch an
traditioneller viertwährung festhalten
wenn also ihr Ansatz nur
grenzüberschreitende Zahlungen sind
brauchen sie keine digitale
einzelhandelswährung unterschiedliche
Währungen spielen also in diesem
Szenario keine Rolle das heißt
Zentralbanken geben digitale Währungen
direkt an die Öffentlichkeit raus und
wir sehen im Moment keinen Bedarf für
eine separate einzelhandelswährung ein
digitaler Euro würde also die Effizienz
eines modernen Zahlungsmittels bieten
und wäre gleichzeitig sicheres
Zentralbankgeld es würde sich dort
anbieten wo Menschen ungern mit Bargeld
bezahlen der Schutz der Privatsphäre
sollte beim Euro einen hohen Stellenwert
haben so kann er dazu beitragen dass
Vertrauen in den heutigen
Zahlungsverkehr aufrecht zu erhalten er
könnte den Übergang der europäischen
Wirtschaft in die Digitalisierung
unterstützen und Innovationen im
massenzahlungsverkehr aktiv fördern
derzeit prüfen die EZB und die
nationalen Zentralbanken des Euroraums
welche Vorteile und Risiken ein
digitaler Euro hätte denn der Anstieg
von Vermögenswerten wie bitcoin ist
größer als die damalige südseeblase oder
die niederländische tulpenblase
[Musik]
nun wissen Sie unser Ansatz ist diese
Art von Vermögenswerten erstmal genau zu
prüfen für uns ist Bitcoin keine Währung
es ist für uns klar eine Wertanlage es
ist ein Vermögens dem nur sehr wenig
zugrunde liegt was zu einer Menge
Volatilität führt sehen Sie wenn man
hier versucht herauszufinden was der
wirkliche Wert des Assets ist in dass
man investiert hat stößt man schnell auf
Schwierigkeiten und das ist genau der
Punkt das Renditen dieser Art von
kryptowertanlagen nicht mit der Rendite
anderer Anlagen vergleichbar sind
deshalb müssen Anleger die in Krypto
Vermögenswerte investiert haben ihr
Portfolio so gut es geht streuen
meiner Meinung nach macht es nicht viel
Sinn hier zu investieren da man das
Problem der starken Volatilität hat vor
ein paar Monaten hatten wir noch die
Situation dass die Preise durch die
Decke schossen und nun sehen sie ja wo
bestehen das macht das alles sehr
schwierig
wenn Sie also Schwierigkeiten haben
herauszufinden was die eigentliche Basis
oder Grundlage ihrer Investition ist
dann denke ich haben sie keine wirkliche
Investition getätigt sondern spekuliert
auch wenn es sich anders anfühlt diese
starken Preisschwankungen zeigen dass es
nur wenig Vertrauen zum Beispiel in
stable gibt wo ein pricesart eine
Währung sollte somit keine Anlage für
Spekulationen sein oder in diese
Richtung Anreize schaffen sondern ein
stabiles Element unserer Geldpolitik
darstellen
würde also ein digitaler Euro nicht zu
den Krypto assets-zellen Krypto Assets
unterscheiden sich grundlegend von
Zentralbankgeld ihre Preise unterliegen
häufig großen Schwankungen so dass sie
nur schwer als konstantes Zahlungsmittel
zu verwenden sind zudem steht hinter
ihnen meist keine vertrauenswürdige
Institution
der Zahlungsverkehr befindet sich im
Umbruch und die Zentralbanken spielen
dabei eine wichtige Rolle Grundlage des
europäischen Zahlungsverkehrs muss ein
wettbewerbsfähiger und innovativer
zahlungsmarkt sein der die Bedürfnisse
der VerbraucherInnen erfüllt und die
Souveränität Europas war
Fachleute der EZB und der nationalen
Zentralbanken des Euroraums haben eine
Reihe grundlegender Anforderungen für
einen digitalen Euro festgelegt
beispielsweise muss er leicht zugänglich
robust sicher und effizient sein
es gibt also eine Menge Punkte die bei
der Einführung einer digitalen Währung
zu beachten sind Mainz auch der
ehemalige CFO von Goldman Sachs Martin
Chavez ich kann leider noch nicht sagen
welche Form genau die digitalwährung
einer Zentralbank annehmen wird es ist
nicht mal zu 100% klar ob dieser auf
einer blockchain existieren muss oder
nicht sie muss auf jeden Fall weit
verbreitet sein die Privatsphäre muss
geschützt sein und es sollte eine
gewisse Fehlertoleranz geben wir sehen
hier auf diesem Gebiet geopolitische
Überlagerungen und das einige Staaten
wie zum Beispiel China dieses Thema sehr
aggressiv angehen und eine digitale
Währung einführen ich weiß zwar nicht
wie die Gespräche hinter verschlossenen
Türen aussehen aber natürlich möchte man
den internationalen Handel gerne in
dieser Währung abwickeln als bisher in
Dollar auf der anderen Seite ist man
noch sehr skeptisch da vielleicht
Überwachung eine große Rolle spielt oder
sogar seine Souveränität an die Nutzung
der digitalen Währung geknüpft ist der
Schutz der Privatsphäre die Bekämpfung
von Geldwäsche und die Transparenz
Sekunden das ist alles sehr sehr
schwierig in Gleichgewicht zu bringen
aber ich möchte auf etwas anderes
zurückkommen dass ich vor zehn Jahren
den früheren Bitcoin ziehe aus
prophezeit habe und ich denke es hängt
damit zusammen damals meinte ich dass
sich sehr zuversichtlich bin dass die
Fett die Digitalisierung des US-Dollars
fortsetzen wird und eines Tages wird er
ein digitales asset sein quasi eine
kryptowährung es hieß das würde nie
passieren aber ich sagte sagt niemals
nie und nun bin ich sicher dass es in
naher Zukunft passieren wird es gibt
Unterschiede in der Denkweise von Leuten
an Ost- und Westküste die Art und Weise
wie in Silicon Valley an Sachen
herangegangen wird unterscheidet sich
doch sehr von der in New York oder DC
aber irgendwann wird es auch hier ein
Umdenken geben
wir können die Vorboten bereits sehen
wer die Beratungen des Kongresses in den
Tiefen der Pandemie genau verfolgt hat
wurde vielleicht an die früheren
konjunkturgesetze der Federal Reserve
Bank erinnert einen digitalen US-Dollar
zu schaffen und diesen an die Amerikaner
zu verteilen
ich weiß noch wie ich dachte das ist
wirklich eine gute Idee
aber es ist und bleibt einen wirklich
unglaublich riesiges Projekt es gibt
sowohl für den groß als auch für den
Einzelhandel die Möglichkeit das
Zahlungssystem weiter zu modernisieren
und sie werden mit der Digitalisierung
noch lange zu kämpfen haben bis Ihr
Bankkonto ein komplett digitales
Konstrukt sein wird
die Frage ist wollen wir dass es
kontobasiert ist soll es genauso
funktionieren wie unsere papiertoller
Scheine nur eben als digitaler Token das
sind alles Themen die im Moment sehr
aktiv diskutiert werden ich erinnere
mich noch als der argentinische Peso an
den Dollar gekoppelt war das war
großartig man konnte Pesos am
Geldautomaten bekommen und das lag daran
dass die währungsbehörde beide Währungen
Dollars und Pesos gleichermaßen
verfügbar machte und das ist jetzt die
Herausforderung bei den stable Coins
ich denke es ist eine absolute
Notwendigkeit jetzt einen digitalen
Dollar an Umlauf zu bringen
Amerika und die Federal Reserve sind
hier in Zugzwang und nicht nur wieder so
eine Übergangslösung nein ich denke es
ist unvermeidlich dass wir jetzt Nägel
mit Köpfen machen denn wenn wir etwas
aus der Politik Wissenschaft kennen ist
es Souveränität einzuhalten ein
souveräner Staat kann seine Steuern nur
in der Währung verlangen die er auch
ausgibt und das ist ja auch gerade das
was die Zirkularität dieser Währung noch
unterbindet
was wäre wenn der gesamte internationale
Handel in ich hören bezahlt und alles
reibungslos gegen den digitalen Türen
getauscht werden könnte würden ihn die
Leute dann tatsächlich verwenden
vielleicht würde ich ein Konto für Juan
eröffnen okay man müsste mich erst
einmal davon überzeugen dass meine
Privatsphäre geschützt wird und nicht
einfach nur sagen dass es so ist es
müsste mathematisch kryptografisch
garantiert sein dass meine Privatsphäre
gewahrt wird und ich bin mir vollkommen
sicher dass solche Gespräche gerade
stattfinden
Martin scharvis spricht hier einen
wichtigen Punkt an wie sieht es aus mit
der Akzeptanz eines digitalen Euros es
wurden Bedenken geäußert das
Zentralbanken durch die Einführung einer
eigenen digitalen Währung in den
besitzsensibler Informationen über die
nutzer:innen gelangen könnten bei privat
imitierten zahlungsinstrumenten wie zum
Beispiel stable Coins ist das Risiko in
den besitzssensibler Informationen zu
gelangen sehr groß die meisten
nutzer:innen und investor:innen sind
auch besorgt dass neu entstehende
private Zahlungslösungen insbesondere
wenn sie unreguliert sind cyber-risiken
mit sich bringen könnten im Falle eines
digitalen Euros könnten solche Risiken
durch die Beteiligung der Zentralbank
gemildert werden eine globale
Meinungsumfrage zum öffentlichen
Vertrauen in monetäre Institutionen
zahlungsmerkmale und digitale Währungen
zeigt die Bedeutung des Vertrauens in
die zugrunde liegenden Systeme während
rund 79% aller Zahlungen im Euroraum
immer noch bargeldtransaktionen sind
Sankt der Anteil dieser Transaktionen
zwischen 2017 und 19 allein in den
Niederlanden von 41 auf 32 Prozent
gerade junge Europäerinnen machen laut
jüngsten ezb-umfragen ausgiebig Gebrauch
von Bargeld bevorzugen aber
elektronische Zahlungen und erwarten von
der entsprechenden Infrastruktur dass
sie Sicherheit und Schnelligkeit
garantiert auch die Corvette 19 Krise
hat zu einer Verschiebung der
Zahlungsgewohnheiten hin zu kontaktlosen
Zahlungen und E-Commerce geführt diese
Verlagerung hin zu kontaktlosen
Zahlungen von Stadt obwohl Banknoten im
Vergleich zu anderen Arten von
Oberflächen mit denen Menschen im
täglichen Leben in Kontakt kommen kein
besonders großes Risiko einer
coronavirus-infektion darstellen in der
Pandemie beschleunigte sich das
Innovationstempo und die bürger:innen
zeigen eine zunehmende Vorliebe für
digitale Zahlungen vor diesem
Hintergrund hat der EZB-Rat im Januar
2020 eine hochrangige Taskforce
eingerichtet um die Arbeit an digitalen
zentralbankwährungen im Euroraum
voranzutreiben würde ein digitaler Euro
also von der EZB zentral verwaltet
werden Brian Brooks war lange Zeit Teil
des Bankensystems und meint
Dezentralität ist der Schlüssel in
meinem letzten Job für die Regierung und
Leitung des Bankensystems haben wir
versucht klar zu machen dass wir weder
Fanatiker noch Feinde von
kryptowährungen sind aber wir glauben
dass die Märkte Richtlinien und Klarheit
brauchen ich sage nicht dass mehr oder
weniger Kontrolle eine gute Sache ist
aber eine Reihe von Regeln zu haben wäre
für mich gut vorstellbar stellen sich
nun mal vor Straßen ohne Tempolimit
niemand weiß ob man schnell oder langsam
fahren soll das wäre fahrlässig wir
haben Tempolimit an die sich jeder
halten kann und so etwas brauchen wir
auch bei kryptowährungen ich denke die
Anziehungskraft von Krypto liegt eher in
der Dezentralisierung und weniger in der
fehlenden Regulierung denn hier liegt
die wahre Herausforderung worum es hier
wirklich geht ist der Aufbau eines
Finanzsystems abseits der
Zentralisierung Leute die denken wir
versuchen geheimes magisches
internetgeld zu erschaffen das nicht
überwacht werden kann sind
wahrscheinlich in der falschen Branche
es geht um ein dezentrales Finanzsystem
das nicht von Bankern kontrolliert wird
das wird der große Vorteil der
kryptowährungen sein
und was ist mit der Stabilität zumindest
wenn man sich andere Märkte anschaut
Stabilität ist oft mit Zentralisierung
verbunden oder wahr zumindest eine Folge
davon schließlich hatten die USA eine
dezentralisierte Wirtschaft bis man sich
entschied eine Fett zu gründen um eine
Art von Stabilität zu erzeugen doch wenn
wir hier ein System von Regeln wie zum
Beispiel Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen
wollen gleich das nicht schon fast einer
Zentralisierung
[Musik]
wir haben die Pferde im 19 Jahrhundert
nicht gegründet weil die
Dezentralisierung schlecht war sondern
weil wir keine technologische
Möglichkeit hatten den Menschen zu
erlauben direkt miteinander zu handeln
und so musst du jemand Dollar in Umlauf
bringen die überall akzeptiert werden
konnten aber jetzt haben wir eine
Technologie die das für uns tut sehen
Sie in der Vergangenheit war die Post
die einzige Möglichkeit um Informationen
auszutauschen es gab für jemanden in New
York keine Möglichkeit Nachrichten nach
San Francisco zu übermitteln jetzt haben
wir E-Mail und brauchen die Post nicht
mehr so verdrängen Technologien manchmal
ganze Institutionen die wir zuvor
aufgebaut haben wenn wir also weiterhin
nach alter Stabilität suchen würde ich
sagen ist diese sehr brüchig es war zwar
stabil aber es wurde alles streng
reguliert und kontrolliert es war auch
unglaublich teuer und hat letztendlich
nicht gut funktioniert es war lediglich
das Beste was wir hatten nun haben wir
etwas Besseres
die EZB ist die Hüterin des Euros ob es
sich um Banknoten und Münzen oder um
einen Euro in digitaler Form handelt
spielt dabei keine Rolle unsere Aufgabe
ist es den Wert unserer gemeinsamen
Währung zu erhalten unabhängig von
seiner Form soll ein digitaler Euro
letztendlich von der zuständigen
Zentralbank geschützt und reguliert
werden ein wesentlicher Teil der Aufgabe
des Eurosystems besteht darin die
bürger:innen mit risikolosem Geld für
ihre Zahlungen zu versorgen bargeld ist
zwar immer noch das vorherrschende
Zahlungsmittel doch neue Technologien
und die zunehmenden Nachfrage der
VerbraucherInnen nach Unmittelbarkeit
verändern die Art und Weise wie die
europäischen Bürgerinnen bezahlen dies
zeigt sich in der rasanten Zunahme
elektronischer Zahlungen
System es gibt einen guten Grund dafür
dass der Umlauf durch das Bankensystem
reguliert wird weil Banken nämlich aus
der monetären Basis ihrer Kreditvergaben
sozusagen dem kreditschöpfungsprozess
Geld erschaffen
wenn die Zentralbanken nun direkt
digitale Währungen an die Allgemeinheit
ausgeben würden was würden dann die
Zentralbanken mit diesem digitalen Geld
machen das Geld der Zentralbanken ist
nicht darauf ausgerichtet Leuten den
Kreditrahmen zu vergrößern das ist die
Aufgabe der Banken wir müssen also
darüber nachdenken wie das in der Praxis
funktionieren soll und man muss auch
fragen warum überhaupt warum sollen die
Zentralbanken die digitalen Währungen
ausgeben mal abgesehen von den
grenzüberschreitenden Zahlungen für den
Einzelhandel ich denke es ist vielmehr
eine geldpolitische Frage als eine rein
politische
people feel the die Menschen haben das
Gefühl ein digitales äquivalent zu
Bargeld zu brauchen dass alle
Eigenschaften von Bargeld hat also
Anonymität und vollkommene Akzeptanz um
nur die beiden wichtigsten zu nennen
wenn ich eine Banküberweisung auf Ihr
Konto mache ist das allenfalls
vertraulich
aber wenn die Behörden den Verdacht
haben dass etwas nicht stimmt können Sie
die Transaktion aufheben und untersuchen
so verfolgen wir ja Geldwäsche oder
Steuerhinterziehung und können diese
aufdecken denn es gibt immer eine
digitale Spur die
transaktionsaufzeichnung wenn wir nun
komplett auf einen digitalen
Zahlungsverkehr umsteigen verlieren die
Leute genau diese absolute Anonymität
des Bargelds wenn ich ihnen einen Koffer
voller Bargeld gebe gibt es keine
Möglichkeit das zurückzuverfolgen
das ist
warum braucht es dann überhaupt
Zentralbank Geld bzw einen digitalen
Euro für Haushalte und Firmen in einer
zunehmend verzahnten und vor allem
digitalisierten Welt hinkt der
Zahlungsverkehr dem Tempo der Wirtschaft
oft noch hinterher
Regulierungen Sorgfaltspflichten und
unterschiedliche IT-Systeme zwischen
Banken und Währungsräumen können gerade
bei Auslandsüberweisungen noch immer
Tage dauern das ist nicht nur
ineffizient sondern erzeugt auch
zusätzliche Kosten Bitcoin oder
facebook-währung diem beabsichtigen
genau dieses Problem zu beheben jedoch
nicht ganz ohne Risiken für nutzer:innen
dafür die Stabilität der Währung
schließlich keiner garantiert wie die
hohen Preisschwankungen von Bitcoin
deutlich machten ein digitaler Euro als
Wertanlage der in unbegrenztem Umfang
verfügbar ist wäre daher auch nichts
wegdienlich Vorteile würden damit nur
indirekt entstehen wenn Transaktionen
beispielsweise beim Onlinekauf schneller
abgewickelt werden und Firmen Direktor
und transparenter Überblick über
Kontostände und Transaktionen hätten die
immer wieder geäußerte Angst die EZB
wolle damit den Leuten das Bargeld
wegnehmen ist daher haltlos die von der
EZB initiierte digitale Revolution wäre
also für anleger:innen und
investor:innen anfangs nicht spürbar
[Musik]
das bringt uns zu Libra wir hatten VISA
Mastercard die sich zurückzogen
die G7 starten mahnten zur Vorsicht wir
stehen Sie dazu da er Facebook sagt dass
die Regulierungsbehörden die Regulierung
hinauszögern und das gleichbedeutend
damit ist Innovation zu deckeln bzw zu
bremsen
wir begrüßen die Innovation ich denke
der Ansatz von facebook hat eine enorme
Menge an neuen Ideen und eine neue Art
zu denken hervorgebracht was meiner
Meinung nach essentiell für die Zukunft
ist und wie sie eben gesagt haben hat
das Interesse der Zentralbanken an
digitalen Währungen durch das Projekt
von Facebook an großen Schub bekommen
on the Faser wird die Kernaussage von
Facebook ist dass es
grenzüberschreitende Zahlungen billiger
schneller und besser machen will und es
will die finanzielle Inklusion
verbessern weil es viel einfacher ist
ein Facebook-Konto zu haben als ein
Bankkonto auf den ersten Blick sind das
hochgesteckte Ziele aber ich denke
Zentralbanken und die bankengemeinschaft
müssen hier an Antworten für Firmen wie
Facebook arbeiten denn so etwas brauchen
wir Banking Community
work on das wurde in gewisser Hinsicht
etwas verschlafen und wenn überhaupt
nicht gut umgesetzt ich will damit nicht
sagen dass facebook-ansatz schlechte
aber er zeigt hier eine echte Lücke auf
und ich verstehe die Idee dahinter
eine weitere Nuance in der ganzen
Problematik der Zentralbank und der
digitalen Währung ist die Frage geht es
hier nur um Zahlungen geht es hier nur
um Anonymität ich denke der ganze
Widerstand hat auch mit der Dominanz des
US-Dollars zu tun ob das eine gesunde
Sache für die globale Finanzstabilität
ist denn wenn zwei Länder miteinander
Handel treiben oder zwei Menschen
Transaktionen durchführen wird immer
auch ein Teil des Dollars umgerechnet
unsere Wechselkurse die bilateralen
Wechselkurse beziehen sich alle auf den
US-Dollar
so
sehr ist das nun eine gute oder
schlechte Sache nun das System hat bis
jetzt ziemlich gut funktioniert doch für
die Zukunft ist es nicht unvernünftig zu
fragen ob das noch der beste Weg ist
hier weiterzukommen oder ob wir nicht
ein stabileres System von globalen
Reservewährungen finden sollten es soll
sich ja nicht wieder alles um die Ver
die Staaten drehen
[Musik]
dies wäre die Denkweise der Regulatoren
und Zentralbanken wir haben hier eine
starke Konzentration auf den US-Dollar
und das ist ein Risiko was ist wenn das
schief geht wollen wir nicht etwas das
ein bisschen mehr diversifiziert ist ich
denke das sind die Fragen mit der sich
die zentralbankengemeinschaft
auseinandersetzen
Bitcoin oder Facebooks Libra haben viele
der Zentralbanken zum Nachdenken
gebracht
digitale zentralbankwährungen auf der
blockchain sogenannte cbdc sind ein seit
2018 intensiv diskutiertes Thema viele
Zentralbanken der Welt diskutieren
bereits ihre Einführung oder planen Sie
konkret
wir werden also bald einen digitalen
Euro haben
aber was bedeutet das überhaupt hinter
dem digitalen Euro steht nämlich kein
Konzern und auch keine Geschäftsbank
sondern die Europäische Zentralbank und
das wichtigste Ziel der EZB ist
Preisstabilität einfacher gesagt ein
Brot kostet mit dem digitalen Euro in
Zukunft noch genauso viel wie jetzt mit
der Mastercard und genau das ist seit
dem Aufkommen und der immer höheren
Akzeptanz von kryptowährungen wie
Bitcoin und Co nicht mehr so einfach
über diese Zahlungsmittel vor allem
deren unberechenbare Wertsteigerungen
bzw Verluste haben die Zentralbanken
keine Kontrolle die EZB möchte dem
entgegenwirken und stattdessen eine
stabile digitale Währung als
Weiterentwicklung des klassischen Euros
einführen
das hieße dass wir neben den jetzigen
Zahlungsmöglichkeiten Bar oder per Karte
eine dritte bekommen einen
elektronischen Euro den wir über das
Smartphone aber auch offline über eine
Datenkarte nutzen können viele
Finanzexperten halten das für längst
überfällig denn in den meisten
skandinavischen Ländern kann kaum noch
mit Bargeld gezahlt werden und darauf
muss die EZB reagieren der Zeit prüft
die EZB unter welchen Voraussetzungen
dieses digitale Zentralbankgeld sicher
eingeführt werden könnte ezb-chefin
Lagarde betonte in einem bloombird
Exklusiv-Interview wiederholt wie
wichtig es sei die Sicherheit einer
digitalen Währung zu garantieren und das
Vertrauen in diese zu stärken okay ich
lege jetzt mal meine eigene Überzeugung
ab weil ich die Präsidentin der
Europäischen Zentralbank bin
es gibt ein Verwaltungsrat in dem alle
Präsidenten der nationalen Zentralbanken
sowie die Mitglieder des Direktoriums
vertreten sind und die Entscheidung ob
wir ein digitalen Euro einführen werden
oder nicht wird von diesem or also dem
Direktorium und dem Rat der
Zentralbanken getroffen mit und das wird
Mitte des Jahres 2021 passieren wenn wir
die ersten Ergebnisse vorliegen
dieser Bericht wird eine Analyse von
über 8000 Rückmeldungen veröffentlichen
die wir im Rahmen des Beratungsprozesses
erhalten haben er wird dem Europäischen
Parlament vorgetragen einem der
Hauptakteure sowie der Kommission und
dem EU-Rat nicht zu vergessen der
Euro-Gruppe
wenn auf der dort mit danach wird der
EZB-Rat auf Grundlage dieser Beratung
und unserer vorangegangenen Arbeit
entscheiden ob wir mit dem Experiment
digitale Euro weitermachen
daraufhin wird es eine zweite
Entscheidung geben wahrscheinlich in
einem Jahr oder lassen Sie es sechs
Monate sein ob aufgrund dieser ersten
Bewertung tatsächlich schon ein
digitaler Euro eingeführt wird
aber lassen Sie uns das realistisch
betrachten der ganze Prozess wird meiner
Meinung nach noch weitere vier Jahre
dauern vielleicht noch etwas länger also
ich hoffe natürlich dass wir es
innerhalb von vier Jahren schaffen aber
es bringt eine Menge technische Aspekte
als auch grundlegende Veränderungen mit
sich und wir müssen sicherstellen dass
wenn wir ein digitalen Euro einführen
wäre es vernünftig machen das sind wir
den Europäern schuldig die Europäer und
Europäerin sollen sicher und unbesorgt
damit umgehen können sie sollen wissen
dass sie Zentralbank gesichert das Geld
erhalten
ich würde sagen es muss das Äquivalent
eine digitalen Banknote sein mit dem
gleichen Maß an Sicherheit und
Rückendeckung durch die Zentralbank so
es muss also wirklich sicher und stabil
sein
wir müssen außerdem sicherstellen dass
wir nicht unser Bankensystem zerstören
sondern es verbessern
ich sage das hier sehr deutlich da ich
weiß dass bestimmte Finanzinstitute mit
denen wir zurzeit arbeiten sich für uns
verlassen
einige Banken schauen gerade ziemlich
besorgt auf diese Entwicklung am
Finanzmarkt aber das brauchen sie nicht
denn keine Zentralbank wird zukünftig
als Kundenmanager oder risikobewerter
für die Vergabe von Kreditlinien
auftreten
diese Finanzinstitute werden also
weiterhin koexistieren und ihre
Geschäfte tätigen können Bargeld wird
auch weiterhin verfügbar sein ebenso wie
digitale Währung
aber man muss sich das auch anschauen
wie sich das Verhalten der bürger:innen
während der kovid 19-krise geändert hat
wie sie im Internet einkaufen oder die
Art und Weise wie sehr Essen bestellen
oder bezahlen
dies bewegt sich bereits in einer
digitalen Dimension vor der wir keine
Angst haben sollten und wie ich schon
sagte wir müssen in Europäern und
Europäerinnen einen sicheren stabilen
Alternativen zahlungsmechanismus bieten
alles
also weitere vier Jahre Entwicklungszeit
haben wir diese Zeit noch um einen
durchdachtes und technisch ausgereiftes
digitales Eurosystem einzuführen
die Ausgabe eines digitalen Euros wäre
für fast alle Tätigkeiten des
Eurosystems von Bedeutung und hätte
weitreichende Auswirkungen auf die
gesamte Gesellschaft gleichzeitig sind
aber auch Experimente zu den praktischen
Aspekten eines digitalen Euros notwendig
um die Stärken und Schwächen der
verschiedenen Optionen zu untersuchen
wir haben gehört dass viele Banken um
ihre Existenz fürchten die Einführung
eines digitalen Euros könnte die
Transmission der Geldpolitik
beeinträchtigen und sich negativ auf die
Finanzstabilität auswirken auch in
Krisensituationen wenn die Sparer
weniger Vertrauen in den gesamten
Bankensektor haben könnten liquidemittel
sehr schnell in den digitalen Euro
umgeschichtet werden
wenn also das Abheben von digitalen Geld
einfacher wird als das Abheben von
Bargeld könnte es die Wahrscheinlichkeit
von schweren bankrunds erhöhen und die
Finanzstabilität Schwächen
diese Beispiele machen deutlich dass die
Ausgestaltung des digitalen Euros
sorgfältig geprüft werden muss es sollte
vor allem überlegt werden ob er für
Haushalte und Unternehmen direkt oder
indirekt über Banken zugänglich sein
sollte ob er für gütet und ob die
digitalen Euro Bestände einzelner
nutzer:innen begrenzt oder unbegrenzt
sein sollten
[Musik]
für den Moment halten wir uns die Option
offen ob und wann dies geschehen soll
Aufgabe der EZB ist es das Vertrauen in
das Geld zu sichern es muss
sichergestellt werden dass der Euro fit
für das digitale Zeitalter ist
die Kommission der EZB hat einiges
Szenarien beschrieben die das Eurosystem
zur Ausgabe eines digitalen Euros
veranlassen könnte und auch
Anforderungen aufgeführt die die neue
Geldform erfüllen sollte
Szenario 1 positive Auswirkungen auf
Innovation und Autonomie der Eurozone
Unabhängigkeit und Digitalisierung der
europäischen Wirtschaft können von einer
digitalen Form des zentralbankgeldes
profitieren die den Bürgern zur
Verfügung gestellt wird die Ausgabe
eines digitalen Euros kann ein Weg sein
die Digitalisierung der Wirtschaft zu
fördern und die Entwicklung innovativer
europäischer Lösungen in allen möglichen
Branchen zu unterstützen in einem
solchen Szenario würde die Ausgabe eines
digitalen Euros dazu beitragen die
europäische Autonomie im Bereich des
massenzahlungsverkehrs zu erhalten und
könnte ein Baustein für eine europäische
Lösung für Point of Sale und
onlinezahlungen sein
Szenario 2 die Rolle von Bargeld als
Zahlungsmitteln nimmt deutlich ab die
europäischen Bürgerinnen hätten somit
Schwierigkeiten auf das einzige
Zahlungsmittel zuzugreifen das vom
öffentlichen Sektor bereitgestellt wird
extreme Ereignisse wie Corvette 19
können die Veränderung der
Zahlungsgewohnheiten beschleunigen durch
steigende Wartungskosten der
bargeldinfrastruktur könnte der Rückgang
der Verfügbarkeit und Akzeptanz von
Bargeld zusätzlich vorangetrieben werden
ein ähnlicher Trend wird sich
wahrscheinlich aus der rasanten
Entwicklung des elektronischen Handels
ergeben
Szenario 3 eine andere Geldform als
eurodominiertes Zentralbank Geld oder
elektronisches Geld wird zu einer
glaubwürdigen Alternative zu Wert
aufbewahrungsmitteln in der Eurozone
private Akteure wie Bitcoin oder Libra
welche außerhalb der Aufsicht der
europäischen Finanzbehörden stehen oder
auch big Tech Unternehmen die nicht Euro
dominiert sind welche eine globale
Verbreitung erreichen und für große
Zahlungen im Euroraum genutzt werden
könnten die Geldpolitik im Euroraum
Schwächen ihr Einfluss hätte auch
unklare Auswirkungen auf die
grenzüberschreitende Kapitalmobilität
was letztlich die Finanzstabilität
beeinträchtigen könnte unter diesen
Umständen könnte die Ausgabe eines
digitalen Euros die europäische
Souveränität und Stabilität unterstützen
Szenario 4 die EU beschließt
Verbesserungen der Gesamtkosten und des
ökologischen Fußabdrucks seiner Geld-
und Zahlungssysteme proaktiv zu
unterstützen die Herstellung von
zahlungsinstrumenten und deren
Infrastrukturen ist nicht immer
energieeffizient ein gut konzipierter
digitaler Euro kann daher dazu beitragen
die Gesamtkosten und den ökologischen
Fußabdruck der Zahlungssysteme im
Euroraum zu verringern in diesem
Zusammenhang würde das Eurosystem eine
katalysatorrolle spielen und mit gutem
Beispiel vorangehen indem es Anreize
schafft und Druck auf die Anbieter von
Zahlungsdienstleistungen ausübt
aus diesen vier Szenarien lassen sich
folgende Anforderungen ableiten der
digitale Euro sollte so gestaltet sein
dass etwaige negative Auswirkungen auf
die Geldpolitik und Finanzstabilität
abgeschwächt werden die übermäßigen
Nutzung des digitalen Euros als
Anlageform und des damit verbundenen
Risikos großer Umschichtungen sollten
vermieden werden der digitale Euro
sollte im Vergleich zu alternativen ein
effizienter Weg sein die ökonomischen
und ökologischen Ziele der Eurozone zu
erreichen
[Musik]
aber bei all den Visionen und Ideen
sehen wir nicht in der technischen
Umsetzung die größte Herausforderung
wie kann für den Endverbraucher den
Lieferanten oder den Unternehmer
sichergestellt werden dass ein digitale
Euro jederzeit verfügbar ist und überall
akzeptiert wird
und welche Rolle spielt dabei der Faktor
Zeit
China testet bereits seine staatliche
digitalwährung namens echuan es kommen
bereits Apps zum Einsatz mit denen
Zahlungen in echuan realisiert werden
können sogar staatliche Leistungen
werden zum Teil in der neuen
digitalwährung ausgezahlt
mit dem digitalen cyan reagiert China
auf kryptowährungen wie Bitcoin dabei
setzt Tinas digitalwährung nur teilweise
auf eine blockchain es kommen auch
traditionelle verrechnungsmethoden zum
Einsatz auch Facebooks Libra oder jetzt
diem sollte nutzer:innen auf Plattformen
wie WhatsApp oder Instagram die
Möglichkeit geben die digitale Währung
beim Onlineshopping zu nutzen Facebook
stieß allerdings weltweit in der Politik
und bei den Notenbanken auf Widerstand
viele sahen in dem Projekt einen Angriff
des Privatunternehmens auf das
staatliche währungsmonopol und kündigten
eine starke Regulierung von privaten
digitalwährungen an Brian Brooks der CEO
von binance befürchtet dass wir ohne
Regulierungen unsere Geldpolitik keine
digitalen Währungen erfolgreich
realisieren können
nach meiner persönlichen Ansicht ist
hier in erster Linie der Nutzen zu
betrachten darüber sollten wir sprechen
bitte bedenken Sie dass jede
kryptowährung eine andere Funktion
repräsentiert das sind alles
verschiedene Netzwerke die für
unterschiedliche Dinge entworfen werden
wenn wir also über Bitcoin sprechen ist
er im Grunde einen Investment asset also
eine Art digitales Gold und wenn Bitcoin
reguliert werden sollte sollte es ebenso
wie Investitionsgüter reguliert werden
es ist natürlich kein Wertpapier aber es
ist etwas das die Leute wegen seiner
werterhaltungseigenschaften kaufen und
halten im Gegensatz zu iterien das ist
ein Netzwerk für Zahlungsverkehr oder
für Crowdsourcing von Finanzierungen
wenn es sich also um einen
zahlungsmechanismus handelt würden sie
erwarten dass die
Bankenaufsichtsbehörden darüber sprechen
das war meine Tätigkeit bei der OCC es
sollte also genau nach Nutzungsklassen
reguliert werden jetzt auch nach asset
Kategorien reguliert wird und wenn es
sich um einen zahlungsmechanismus
handelt sollte er wie ein
zahlungsmechanismus reguliert werden ich
denke das ist hier der richtige
Denkansatz
facebook hat sein Konzept einer
digitalen Währung stark verwandelt um
die Volatilität seines Kurses gering zu
halten soll es zunächst nur einen
sogenannten stable coin geben der
jeweils einen US-Dollar abbildet und
dessen Preis dynamisch bzw automatisch
gesteuert werden kann auch den Namen hat
Facebook geändert der Libra heißt nun
diem Dollar ein Zulassungsantrag für die
Europäische Union ist allerdings noch
nicht eingegangen
warum also zögert die EU somit der
Einführung einer digitalen Währung
Kristin Lagarde meint es geht nur im
Zusammenspiel von Markt und Regulatoren
[Musik]
wir müssen uns mit Fragen des
Datenschutzes befassen und mit vielen
Fragen die in gewisser Weise über den
Bereich der Zentralbanken hinausgehen
das heißt wir sind gezwungen mit anderen
Behörden zusammenzuarbeiten zum Beispiel
den Finanzministerien und dem
Parlamenten der Europäischen Kommission
denn wenn der Zeitpunkt kommt wird es
das Leben vieler Menschen auf eine sehr
intime Weise ändern wir hören den
Europäerinnen zu und wissen was Ihnen
wichtig ist sie wollen dass Ihre
Privatsphäre geschützt ist aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir auch
sicherstellen dass es nicht zu einer
Ausweitung von Geldwäsche oder
terrorfinanzierung führt wir müssen also
bei jedem einzelnen Aspekt die richtige
Balance finden das wird noch ein paar
Jahre dauern und wenn diese Arbeit
abgeschlossen ist wird der Regierungsrat
entscheiden ob er uns hierfür grünes
Licht gibt oder wir die ganze Sache
stoppen ich vermute dass wir für die
nächsten zwei Jahre viel Unterstützung
vom EZB-Rat erwarten können und
hoffentlich das volle Budget
bereitgestellt wird denn das ganze
funktioniert nicht ohne Kosten zu
verursachen aber in zwei Jahren wird
sich dann entscheiden ob es ein Let's Go
ist und wir einen digitalen Euro
bekommen oder nicht nun mit Blick auf
die Märkte haben wir rational versucht
sie zu verstehen oder ihre Gedanken zu
verstehen und was ihre Erwartungen sind
klar ich als Person spreche selbst nicht
mit den Märkten und ich denke das ist
auch nicht mein Aufgabengebiet es ist
sogar meine Pflicht mich daraus zu
halten aber wir haben natürlich Leute
die den Markt beobachten und ihn kennen
ich meine man kann kein großer Einkäufer
sein ohne tatsächlich eine gewisse Nähe
dazu zu haben wie Märkte funktionieren
und wie sie ticken vor allem die
Erwartungen sind von entscheidender
Bedeutung sie führen also marktumfragen
durch an denen die Unternehmen
teilnehmen und die wir genau auswerten
das ist aber nicht die einzige
Komponente wir schauen auf alle
möglichen Indikatoren und Umfragen also
auf indicators
wir sind fest entschlossen und
vollständig auf unser Ziel fixiert die
Preisstabilität zu erhalten die wir den
Europäern und Europäern liefern müssen
das ist für uns das Wichtigste aber die
Märkte spielen natürlich auch eine Rolle
und wir müssen auf sie achten und
überlegen wie sie die Dinge sehen aber
unser Ziel ist natürlich Preisstabilität
die Finanzminister der größten
Eurostaaten unter anderem Deutschland
Frankreich Spanien und Italien haben
sich gegen einen digitalen Schnellschuss
ausgesprochen eine digitale Währung
dürfte nicht eingeführt werden bevor
nicht alle damit verbundenen Risiken
auch in der Gesetzgebung angemessen
berücksichtigt worden sind darüber
hinaus birgt die Einschränkung der
Verwendung eines digitalen Euros die
Gefahr dass die Konvertierbarkeit zu
anderen Formen des Euros beeinträchtigt
wird Zinsänderungen oder Märkte auf
denen der digital Euro wie eine
Parallelwährung behandelt wird stellen
eine Bedrohung für die Verwendung des
Euros als Zahlungsmittel in der
Wirtschaft dar dass die Einführung einer
digitalen Währung durchaus positive
Effekte auf die Stabilität eines Landes
haben kann zeigt sich am Beispiel
Venezuela das Start-up value hilft den
Menschen in Venezuela im Kampf gegen die
Hyperinflation
[Musik]
ich bin Mitbegründer und CEO von value
unser Produkt hilft in venezulernen mit
der Hyperinflation umzugehen und ihr
Geld vor Wertverlust zu schützen
Überweisungen zu erhalten vor Ort zu
bezahlen und um Lebensmittel und
Medikamente zu kaufen
sowohl Unternehmen als auch Verbraucher
sind in der Lage waren und
Dienstleistungen miteinander zu tauschen
und in kryptowährung zu bezahlen unsere
Vision ist es die wirtschaftliche
Freiheit zu erhöhen
venezuela ist bekannt für seine
politische und wirtschaftliche
Instabilität die Hyperinflation hat dazu
geführt dass der boliva in nur zwei
Jahren 99 Prozent seines Wertes verloren
wohlhabende Familien sahen ihr Vermögen
schwinden und einkommensschwache
Menschen wurden noch weiter in die
Verzweiflung getrieben
Simon schamoro kennt diese Geschichte
nur allzu gut
als ich in Venezuela aufwuchs ging im
Grunde alles was mein Vater und meine
Mutter in ihrem Leben aufbauen konnten
verloren als die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrach wir hatten zum Beispiel
Wasserknappheit oder Stromausfälle im
ganzen Land das Geld fing an
hyperinflationär zu werden
das ist keine traurige Geschichte die
ich hier versuche zu erzählen das ist
leider die Realität der meisten
Venezianer mehr als 99 Prozent der
Venezolaner haben alles verloren was sie
aufgebaut haben weil das Land
gescheitert ist alle Ersparnisse aus der
Mittelschicht die sich etwas aufbauen
wollte lösten sich in Luft auf ich
wollte meine Bestimmung finden und
wusste immer dass ich ein Unternehmen
gründen und Dinge entwickeln wollte
weshalb ich dann auch Industriedesign
studierte ich glaubte fest daran in der
Lage zu sein Dinge zu verändern
letztendlich habe ich diese Karriere
nicht weiter verfolgt aber ich habe eine
Menge Dinge gelernt die mir die
Technologie näher gebracht haben und so
bin ich beim Thema Krypto gelandet ich
habe mich dafür begeistert und als ich
dann das Potenzial von Krypto Verstand
wurde mir klar dass Venezuela der
perfekte Ort ist um solche Ideen in
große Maßstab umzusetzen
der reality ist tatsächlich könnte eine
dekonstruierung der kryptowährung der
Mittelschicht helfen und dieser hat die
Möglichkeit unsere Gesellschaft wie wir
sie kennen grundlegend zu verändern
das Hauptproblem der Venezolaner ist im
Moment die Hyperinflation und diese ist
nur das Nebenprodukt einer totalen
Misswirtschaft dieses Landes
[Musik]
Venezuelas Abstieg in eine verarmte
Diktatur hat der Welt die verheerenden
Auswirkungen der Hyperinflation vor
Augen geführt schleppende
Grundversorgung extreme Knappheit an
Lebensmitteln und medizinischen Mitteln
Bürgerkriege Gewalt
Venezulaner die ihre Währung aus
Venezuela in andere stabilere Währungen
wie den US-Dollar transferieren konnten
blieben verschont ein Luxus der meist
nur für die Ultra Elite in Frage kam
mittels kryptowährung möchte Simon mit
seiner Plattform value allen die
Möglichkeit geben sich gegen die
Hyperinflation zu wehren sie seiner
Meinung nach sind die instabilen
Verhältnisse in seinem Land der
perfekten Nährboden für ein solches
Experiment
niemand traut mehr der Währung oder der
Regierung die Menschen suchen nach
Lösungen
an einem Ort an dem die Menschen
versuchen zu überleben ist die
Hemmschwelle viel niedriger neue Dinge
auszuprobieren sei es diesel-dollars
tischmünzen kryptowährungen die Leute
werden bereit sein mit wenig Geld zu
starten und dann langsam versuchen es
irgendwie zu etablieren unser Hauptziel
im Moment als Unternehmen ist es
Händlern zu ermöglichen den Ditto Dollar
als Zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren so
dass die Leute immer weniger gezwungen
sind den Boulevard zu benutzen
wir konzentrieren uns darauf ein Produkt
zu entwickeln das von den Reichen
gebildeten und technisch versierten bis
hin zu den Menschen mit den niedrigen
Einkommen und geringen technischen
Kenntnissen genutzt werden kann in einem
Land wie Venezuela wurde er Mindestlohn
bei ungefähr einem Dollar liegt haben
sie die Situation dass die meisten Leute
ihr eigenes kleines Geschäfte öffnen Hot
Dogs verkaufen oder lokales Essen wie
arretas oder was auch immer aber sie
verkaufen es vorwiegend in ihren super
riesigen Gemeinden also wollen wir den
Gemeinden helfen Zahlungen in Dollar bzw
in dito-dollar also stable Coins zu
akzeptieren und Nutzer zu erreichen je
mehr Verbraucher in Dollar zahlen desto
besser für die Händler je mehr Händlers
akzeptieren umso besser für die
Verbraucher bis heute haben wir
Millionen von Dollar bewegt und haben
damit mehr als 150.000 Haushalten
geholfen
30.000 aktive Nutzer monatlich und wir
sehen dass es funktioniert in
Wirklichkeit kann wirtschaftliche
Freiheit nur direkt durch Innovation
erreicht werden was kryptow sind
dabei darf man nicht vergessen dass
Venezuela dies bereits versucht hat el
Petro war der Versuch einer
kryptowährung zu etablieren die durch
die reichhaltigste Ressource des Landes
unterstützt wurde Öl während el Petro
weithin als durchschlagender Misserfolg
betrachtet wurde sind sich viele
Experten einig dass dieses Experiment
ein notwendiger Schritt war um eine
digitale Währung für die Zukunft zu
etablieren und Simon ist überzeugt dass
deren Grundlage nämlich die
blockchain-technologie nun stärker denn
je benötigt wird und sein Land bereit
ist für einen weiteren Versuch
die blockchain-technologie ist
tatsächlich eine Art Paradigmenwechsel
für die Menschheit eines der
bedeutsamsten Dinge unserer Zeit
man sieht langsam dass immer mehr
Unternehmen damit beginnen ihre Produkte
komplett auf einer blockchain aufzubauen
es ist fast so als würde sich eine
eigene Wirtschaft entwickeln
wenn es einen Weg ohne Krypto gäbe den
venezulanern ihre Stabilität und
wirtschaftliche sowie finanzielle
Freiheit zurückzugeben wäre das
natürlich ein viel besserer Weg als mit
einem Produkt Erfolg zu haben das in
sich gar keinen Wert besitzt
die Hyperinflation Venezuelas zeigt dass
die Geldpolitik eines Landes nicht immer
nach den internationalen Spielregeln
funktioniert
unsere Erwartung die Geldpolitik einer
Zentralbank kann uns jederzeit retten
sollte unser Geld in Schieflage geraten
muss also in Zukunft hinterfragt werden
wenn sogar ein erdölreiches Land wie
Venezuela in eine Hyperinflation geraten
kann einer der diese quantitativen
Lockerungen in der Geldpolitik schon
länger in Frage stellt ist Ravi mennon
[Musik]
ich denke das ist falsch und ich denke
auch es ist falsch wenn Zentralbanken
diese Erwartung zu quantitativen
Lockerungen nähren
die Geldpolitik bildet die Grundlage für
nachhaltiges nicht inflationäres
Wirtschaftswachstum sie sorgt für
Stabilität und zumindest auf mittlere
Sicht für Vorhersagbarkeit und auf
dieser Basis kann man dann wirtschaften
kann aber es kann nicht sein dass jede
Abschwächung jedes Risiko oder jede
wirtschaftliche Bedrohung die am
Horizont auftaucht eine Lockerung der
Geldpolitik nach sich zieht ich denke
dass Fiskalpolitik eine enorm wichtige
Rolle spielt und wir das nicht
ausreichend berücksichtigen auch zum
Teil weil der Geldpolitik zu viel
Gewicht beigemessen wird wir brauchen
hier ein besseres Gleichgewicht zwischen
beiden alles andere wäre auch unfair
gegenüber der zentralbankengemeinschaft
und da sie gerade quantitative
Lockerungen ansprechen Singapur braucht
diese Lockerung nicht weil unsere
Geldpolitik an unseren Wechselkurs
gekoppelt ist wir unterliegen also nicht
der präsenzpolitik selbst wenn man über
Negativzinsen und quantitative
Lockerungen als Ergänzung zu einer
wechselkurszentrierten Geldpolitik
nachdenkt diese Überlegungen Treffen für
uns nicht zu wir können wenn nötig den
Wechselkurs Pfad wieder auf Null
absenken bitte verstehen Sie mich nicht
falsch wir haben noch nie absichtlich
eine Politik der Währungsabwertung
betrieben aber wir können den
Wechselkurs jederzeit wieder nach unten
korrigieren was wir in der Vergangenheit
auch schon getan haben wenn wir der
Meinung sind dass der aktuelle
Wechselkurs zu eng ist können wir in
jeder Zeit nach unten rezentrieren und
mit dieser Flexibilität gibt es
eigentlich keine Einschränkung wir haben
also einen ziemlich großen
geldpolitischen Spielraum ohne dass wir
über quantitative Lockerungen nachdenken
müssen
[Musik]
während die EZB also der Zeit noch an
einem Konzept zum digitalen Euro
arbeitet sind Zentralbanken anderer
Staaten meist schon einen Schritt weiter
2018 gab auch das oberste bankeninstitut
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
Deutsche Bundesbank bekannt aktiv an
einer blockchainbasierten Lösung zu
arbeiten
das Institut mit Hauptsitz in Frankfurt
am Main verwaltet rund 200 Milliarden
Euro an staatlichen Reserven und ist
Teil des europäischen Systems der
Zentralbanken nach eigenen Angaben
intensiviert die Banken und seine
Forschung im Bereich der distributed
Ledger technology und hat bereits einen
entsprechenden Partner genannt Ocean
protocol soll zukünftig mit seiner
Technologie die Deutsche Bundesbank in
ihrem Vorhaben unterstützen das 2017 in
Singapur gegründete Unternehmen
entwickelt innovative Apps für die
kommende datenökonomie und verbindet
Daten Anbieter und Nutzer mit Hilfe der
blockchain-technologie Ocean ermöglicht
es dateneigentümern Daten zu
monetarisieren und gleichzeitig die
Kontrolle über Ihre Datenbestände zu
behalten
die Deutsche Bundesbank ruft also ein
eigenes blockchain-projekt ins Leben der
Fokus dieser Zusammenarbeit liegt
hierbei auf einem dezentralen Netzwerk
das Nutzern einen permanent
symmetrischen Zugriff auf Daten
gestattet dadurch sollen beispielsweise
echtzeits Aktualisierungen von
Statistiken unter Wahrung der
Datenhoheit möglich sein von der
Bundesbank hieß es Ocean protocol war
als einziges Unternehmen in der Lage
eine technische Lösung für unser
Vorhaben anzubieten die bereits
funktionsfähig ist
außerdem soll eine Plattform für die
sichere Verwahrung Übertragung und
Nutzung öffentlicher und privater Daten
entwickelt werden offen bleibt ob das
Unternehmen aus Singapur auch bei der
Forschung an einem digitalen Euro
beteiligt ist
doch wie sieht es mit den deutschen
Unternehmen aus
wie denken diese im allgemeinen über die
Einführung und Nutzbarkeit eines
digitalen Euros
78 Prozent also 3/4 aller Unternehmen ab
50 Beschäftigten sind für die Einführung
eines digitalen Euros
nur jedes fünfte Unternehmen 20 Prozent
hält diese Pläne für wenig
erfolgversprechend das ist das Ergebnis
einer jüngsten Umfrage unter 652
Unternehmen aller Branchen in
Deutschland aus dem Jahr 2021
vor allem die Möglichkeit das sonst
andere privater digitalwährungen zum
Einsatz kommen die europäische Werte
untergraben könnten spricht aus Sicht
der Unternehmen für einen digitalen Euro
69% der Unternehmen sehen es als
notwendig an mit tokinisierten
Wertpapieren nahtlose zahlungs- und
Abwicklungsprozesse auf dem Kapitalmarkt
zu ermöglichen
was genauso viele nämlich 64% denken
dass es von Vorteil ist einen digitalen
Euro zu haben sollte die Bedeutung von
Bargeld abnehmen
so hätten Bürger im digitalen Zeitalter
weiterhin direkten Zugang zur
Zentralbank das an digitaler Euro ist
der EZB in Krisenzeiten ermöglicht
innovative geldpolitische Instrumente
effektiver umzusetzen Glauben 60% der
Befragten
rund 40 Prozent würden gern
Zahlungsprozesse zunehmend
automatisieren und sehen hier den Bedarf
für einen programmierbaren Euro in der
Industrie Stichwort MTM payment also
machine to machinezahlungen im Internet
nur 11% sind der Meinung an digitale
Euro hätte überhaupt keine Vorteile
[Musik]
neben den Verfechtern des digitalen
Zeitalters gibt es allerdings auch
skeptika rund um die Einführung eines
digitalen Euros 65 Prozent also etwa 2/3
sehen hier datenschutzrisiken sollte die
Zentralbank tiefere Einblicke in unsere
Zahlungsprozesse erhalten auch sieht
ungefähr jedes zweite Unternehmen
dadurch die Finanzstabilität gefährdet
denn durch die Ausgabe des digitalen
Euros könnte der Einfluss der Banken in
Krisenzeiten sinken doch nur drei
Prozent der Banken und
Finanzdienstleister halten nichts von
der Ausgabe eines digitalen Euros durch
die EZB
circa 8% der Gesamtwirtschaft meint die
Wirtschaft müsste eigene Lösungen für
den digitalen Zahlungsverkehr der
Zukunft entwickeln 13 Prozent geben an
es spreche nichts gegen einen digitalen
Euro
so sprechen sich 35% des Banken und
Finanzgeschäfts für die Einführung eines
digitalen Euros aus
in der Bewertung zu Tendenz würden 46%
eher einem digitalen Euro zustimmen und
nur 9% sagen klar nein
[Musik]
EZB ist jedenfalls fest entschlossen
einen digitalen Euro einzuführen den
sogenannten e-euro
dieser soll parallel zum Bargeld
ausgegeben werden das ausdrücklich nicht
abgeschafft werden soll damit reagiert
die EZB auf zahlreiche neue Formen des
Bezahlens wie zum Beispiel Krypto Assets
wie etwa Bitcoin diem oder Chinas ich
Johann
[Musik]
ezb-präsidentin Lagarde geht davon aus
dass der e-euro schon in vier Jahren in
den virtuellen Geldbörsen der
VerbraucherInnen der Eurozone liegen
wird und dann auch kräftig zum Einsatz
kommt China ist bei der Entwicklung
einer digitalen Währung weit voraus und
auch Schwedens Zentralbank arbeitet an
der digitalen Krone wie der e-euro am
Ende genau aussieht wissen auch die
Währungshüter noch nicht aber so viel
ist bereits klar der digitale Euro wird
wie Bargeld von der EZB ausgegeben und
kontrolliert es entsteht also wie Münzen
Scheine oder Buchgeld das auf dem
Girokonto oder Sparbuch liegt durch die
Geldschöpfung der EZB und der
Geschäftsbanken im Unterschied zum
Bitcoin und anderen Krypto Assets behält
also die Notenbank die Kontrolle über
die Währung womit Stabilität und
Sicherheit des digitalen Euros
garantiert werden soll der e-euro soll
in einer Art virtuellen Geldbörse
aufbewahrt werden und mittels eines
einfachen Verfahrens zum Beispiel durch
eine App oder einen QR-Code in die
virtuelle Kasse des Verkäufers wandern
dies wird online zum Beispiel via
Internet als auch offline über Bluetooth
möglich sein eine Zahlung soll in
Zukunft also viel einfacher und auch
viel schneller möglich sein als bisher
über SEPA-Überweisung
funktionieren soll das ganze über einen
separates Konto sozusagen einem
direktkonto bei der EZB dennoch
verwaltet durch die Geschäftsbanken so
ist der e-euro selbst dann nur noch
durch die EZB geschützt wenn private
Finanzinstitute durch eine Krise in
Schieflage geraten auch der Schutz der
Privatsphäre ist zunehmend gesichert da
im Unterschied zu großen amerikanischen
Kreditkarten Unternehmen bei der
Transaktion keine persönlichen Daten
übermittelt werden am 14 Juli hat der
Rat der Europäischen Zentralbank
beschlossen das Projekt digitaler Euro
einzuleiten
es wurden eine Menge Analysen
vorgenommen Feedback von BürgerInnen
sowie aus Fachkreisen eingeholt und eine
praktische Erprobung durchgeführt mit
ermutigenden Ergebnissen all dies hat
den Startschuss für das Projekt
digitaler Euro ermöglicht und wer weiß
vielleicht werden wir in vier Jahren mit
dem digitalen Euro genauso
selbstverständlich einkaufen wie bisher
mit Kredit oder Debitkarte die und der
Euroraum sind auf einem guten Weg unser
Finanzsystem kontrolliert und sicher in
das digitale Zeitalter zu führen
der digitale Euro wird ein nächster
großer Schritt in die Zukunft für Europa
und seiner BürgerInnen sein
[Musik]